what is this gonna be about brainstorm
some ideas also we contact a concept
artist started putting together some
rough text and rough imagery even
actually what as far as casting a mini
fake teaser for the piece which was
mostly just cool graphics and some cool
people posing on green screens with guns
the whole point of all this was just to
prove we know how we want to kind of
play our characters and not to mention
hey look at how cool this stuff looks if
we did it in live-action to always say
when I came at it we're inspired by the
multiplayer of battlefield yeah I mean
it has a single-player campaign but
realistically the vast majority of
people spend the time playing the
multiplayer you just have to realize at
its core that is what you have to
embrace when you're gonna design a piece
based off of video games is the common
experience when you pitch a video game
project it's the hardest thing to figure
out all right what is the angle we're
gonna hit hit this with you know a lot
of video game projects in the past that
thing go wrong because they are a
sticking to main characters in these
storylines to try and recreate them be
there trying to 100% recreate likes
settings or memorable iconic things from
the game and where they completely
deviate all together into a mass
audience and there's nothing to do with
the game yeah I mean but the thing is is
that that point you no matter which
option you take you're like pigeon
holing yourself into these like
pre-written pre-made you know linear
things that honestly players have
already experienced well another issue
is yeah a lot of companies have this
ideal of what their game is that doesn't
line up with what the public perceives
it as exactly you know it's like they
want their game to be this and so they
make all their marketing like this they
make all their official stuff like this
but the public doesn't see the game that
yeah and you get this weird mashup at
times and we've dealt with that when
we've done our my various brand
integrations on the channel it's a very
serious war game there's no joke so to
speak about it it's it's this is war
this is battle it's a hundred cent
gritty and 100% serious and then you
flip that around you take a look at all
the videos online of gamers who are
playing it ourselves included and
usually it is you putting a bomb on some
guys but when he's not looking and
blowing about
that's a lot closer to the actual common
experience and so you kind of have to
recognize that you basically just have
to balance both worlds a little bit
everything in terms of just a general
shooting style like how we like to
actually get things done we have a
certain way of operating on settings so
our goal was to take what we've learned
with low-budget micro crew filmmaking
and see how we can apply the best parts
of that - I want your film crew yeah
that's definitely an interesting
challenge and you're running around
shooting with your friends and you're
getting millions to use on the Internet
do you really need to change that if you
move on to a different style project the
answer is yes yes yep
and more on that as you watch the behind
the scenes rush is finally live and if
you're in the u.s. you can go to go 90
comm right now and watch episodes 1 & 2
for free it's super cool
everyone's diggin it